vous n'avez jamais travaillé avec des
détenus
ces petits pas c'était des jeunes en
difficulté qui avait chuté comme un
appareil alors là je m'appelle etienne
je suis comédien on veut faire de ce
cash mission wen ont offert du stand
mais ce que je sais pas trop mon truc je
fais du théâtre un peu bizarre on vous a
jamais vus et conquest ringo starr et
serait pas avec nous tu réfléchis un peu
[Musique]
le plus grand auteur de théâtre du xxème
siècle nous prépare la pièce de domec
dans la merde
j'espère de lendemains meilleurs ça vous
parle pas ça je vais pas qu'ils se
retrouvent en situation d'échec
je suis là pour les tirer vers le haut
vas-y ces rouleaux au boulot
ça veut dire six mois de répétitions et
comment vous voulez que je justifie
serre moi ils vont représenter tous les
autres ils vont devenir des exemples des
ambassadeurs qui s'ils arrivent c'est
pas des acteurs dont moi si moi je vais
faire sa divine aphasie [ __ ] rc même
pas ce que ça veut dire en fait c'est
quoi ce bordel
cette répétition vous n'êtes pas dans un
théâtre ici vous êtes dans une prison
avec des délais un projet criminel
un papa comme ça mon temps je te parle
comme je veux je suis metteur en scène
et si moi je veux que les spectateurs
aient doublé dont vous venez je crois
que nos vidéos vient d'où
le public est saisie du grand théâtre ce
composé les faire une tournée
pas pour eux que tu as fait ça c'est
pour toi et alors je vais pas le droit
d'exister mois a laissé passer cinq ans
étonné mais ça vaut l'emporté avec vos
personne n'a voulu piquer
oh
tu es fâché
ah non j'ai pas fâché non mais je joue
là c'est mon texte abbas était bien
j'étais juge non
[Musique]